más de un año después de entrar en la
casa blanca el presidente estadounidense
joe biden ofreció su primer discurso del
estado de la unión enfocado en la guerra
en ucrania y en las múltiples crisis que
atraviesa su país en referencia a la
guerra responsabilizó a su homólogo ruso
vladimir putin de haber rechazado los
esfuerzos de la diplomacia para llevar
adelante lo que consideró una guerra
injustificada en términos de la pandemia
aseguró que el virus ya no debería
controlar la vida de los estadounidenses
pero que seguiría en el país y también
estarían en guardia con su plan de
vacunación respecto al empleo el
presidente destacó la creación de más de
6.5 millones de trabajo a pesar de la
crisis sanitaria en el último año con
inflación disparada de 7.5 por ciento el
mandatario dijo que su principal
objetivo es reducir la recortando costos
pero no los sueldos de los ciudadanos
estadounidenses
saludamos a brenda stefan analista
internacional de prenda gracias por
estar con nosotros en directo américa de
frança 24 esta mañana de miércoles le
pregunté entonces prestan todos esos
mensajes enviados por by den a vladimir
putin en su discurso muy buenos días yo
creo que el mensaje de ayer en la noche
de baile tiene dos elementos el primero
es un mensaje interno para su
pueblo nacional para los estadounidenses
en donde les dice todo va a estar bien y
quiere tranquilizar al estadounidense de
cara a este conflicto militar que tiene
preocupado al mundo quiere decirles que
se liberarán reservas de petróleo y que
esto buscará disminuir las instrucciones
a los precios
del petróleo y de los combustibles que
terminan por por afectar al ciudadano de
a pie y por otro lado desde luego el
mensaje de cara al mundo diciendo
después de esta guerra rusia saldrá
debilitado y el mundo saldrá fortalecido
y en esta comparación el poner a rusia
versus el mundo está resaltando el hecho
de que la reacción en contra de la
actitud de vladimir putin y de éste a
ucrania es generalizada en el mundo es
decir divide a rusia del mundo
colocándolo como como el gran paria
digamos que se le está convirtiendo con
estas sanciones que van en más allá de
europa y eeuu y se incorporan japón
australia canadá
etcétera y creo que estos son los dos
grandes mensajes que vimos el día de
ayer el tono desde luego el clásico
estadounidense de nosotros son los los
paladines de la libertad un tono que ya
conocemos bien ahora aprenda también
bailes dijo putin no tiene idea de lo
que viene que más puede venir en toda
esta guerra en toda esta invasión rusa y
ucrania
yo creo que lo que hay en este momento
es una guerra también por la
comunicación está este enfrentamiento
militar ha sido muy marcado por una
guerra de discursos de mensajes de
comunicación de percepciones de ambos
lados y en ese sentido creo que el
mensaje un poco de amenaza busca dar la
idea de que hay una posición sólida de
occidente hemos visto al
ministro de economía francés quizás en
un trastabilleo a bruno le maire decir
que se trataba de una guerra total a
nivel comercial y financiero contra
francia después se desdijo quizás porque
los términos no eran los mejores pero en
la realidad lo que estamos viendo es
justamente una creciente escalada de la
sanción es decir no sólo son las que se
anunciaron el fin de semana sino que
minuto a minuto se incorporan cosas
nuevas por parte de compañías de flete
marítimo como 'maersk y por parte de
empresas de petróleo como british
petroleum y entonces
costo digamos de esta guerra sigue
aumentando no se refiere desde ahora a
una intervención militar que ha
reiterado incluso el día de ayer que no
habrá intervención militar directa por
parte de eeuu ni de local y también
brenda el cierre del espacio aéreo
estadounidense a las aeronaves rusas
también vayan se fue digamos de frente
en las sanciones contra oligarcas rusos
son efectivas realmente estas medidas de
presión que toma eeuu
ahora son efectivas para mostrarle a
moscú ya el mundo que esta acción tuvo
un costo alto y que tendrá un costo para
rusia y los rusos en el mediano y futuro
pero en realidad en el corto plazo esto
no va a cambiar la decisión de vladimir
putin de invadir de continuar con esta
guerra es decir esto lo hará que se
retiren las tropas de
ucrania para es eficiente para detener
la guerra no es eficiente para que haya
un costo político económico para rusia y
para el gobierno de vladímir putin si
ahora también brenda retomando no y de
cara a la política interna de eeuu o
bailén dijo como usted viendo decía
también que todo iba a estar bien en el
país se respecto a la pandemia respecto
a la inflación pero todo en este
contexto global cómo hacerlo
claro yo creo que este mensaje era
inevitable digamos por parte de bailén
venimos de un año de dos años muy
complicados de pandemia y los efectos
que tendrán la guerra en el mundo se
harán sentir en cada rincón del planeta
a nivel económico no hay duda que hablen
que habrá inflación sobre todo sobre
todo en el
hidrocarburos el precio de la energía y
en
materias primas y alimentos entonces yo
creo que el mensaje era necesario y
bueno que tan viable es que no hay
efectos que todo esté bien pues yo creo
que difícilmente
no habrá efectos yo creo que los
estadounidenses de a pie se sentirán en
efecto esta gana pero el mensaje el
presidente tendría tenía que ser en este
sentido de tranquilizar a su población
ha sido un año agitado también sobre
todo el que pasó para el presidente joe
biden que también todo esto y todas las
decisiones y la más fuerte digamos que
fue la retirar las tropas de afganistán
afectó muchísimo su popularidad le
pregunto entonces que se espera ver en
estas elecciones de medio término
rechazar a los estadounidenses a los
demócratas por todas estas decisiones
que ha tomado el líder de la casa blanca
yo creo que no hay duda de que los
demócratas en las elecciones de medio
término de este año
perderán la apretada mayoría que tienen
hoy en el congreso y creo que le pasarán
factura de una serie de cosas pero sobre
todo más allá de la recuperación
económica que no ha sido mala está el
tema la inflación que pp pse en el
bolsillo y en la percepción de los
ciudadanos de manera importante y creo
que eso se hará valer en las elecciones
vemos una sociedad estadounidense que
continúa muy dividida un congreso muy
dividido y esto desde luego es algo que
de alguna manera se observa desde pekín
desde moscú que en este momento están
buscando hacer un reequilibrio del poder
a nivel global pues brenda gracias por
su tiempo por su análisis de lo que fue
este primer discurso del estado de la
unión del presidente estadounidense by
den también haciendo por supuesto
referencia y enfocándose en lo que
ocurre en ucrania la guerra en ucrania
luego de después de esta invasión rusa a
brenda gracias por su tiempo